please give it up for our panelist
starting off with ammanuel
ro and next we have Kenia
solo and then we have graci
scon and then last but not least this
man used to give a special Round of
Applause for he created the series
please give it up for Jade
[Applause]
W hi guys hey hey hi so good morning and
welcome to day two of your London
Adventure thank you so how have you
found coming over to London and meeting
all all of the lill fans I mean how's it
been for you all of you bloody
[Applause]
brilliant sorry that was loud see you
picked up the accent I can see a whole
it's all Rachel we're just trying to
learn from Rachel I tell you what I can
see a whole British themed episode next
time you you bet your bottom all right
all right right now they're all looking
at
me all fly out here to shoot an episode
now it was it was looking right eyes of
oh God yes please I was on the tube the
tube the other day and um just being
such a creep listening to people's
conversations trying to pick out words
because you guys have so many amazing
saying I just learned one um oh what was
it a a now I don't what to say cuz I'm
going to say something chck yes chck um
what does it mean again redneck
redneck
you yeah I've been watching Orange is
the New
Black there's a lot of female
friendships on
that enjoyed watching I've been watching
H God sorry uh new
girl yeah I I love um I love their
relationships they're
awesome I love The Walking
Dead I mean that's all can be friends
like the zombie
relationships there there are female
zombie friends on that show yeah J what
about you I watch Big Bang Theory I like
I was Ned when I was a kid that's my
show a question from gentleman in the
middle when was I the F did you use any
specific Source when he was going over
there design of
powers oh yeah we actually have a full
writer room with about a th like
reference books from all over the world
cuz the principle of the show is we're
going to grab these true life monsters
from cultures all over the world we've
used Japanese ones Irish ones Spanish
ones so we actually do research it quite
thoroughly I will not allow them to use
a monster that's not well known in
literature I just want to know uh
because the law school Series has some
amazing on liners if you all have your
own personal oneliner whether it's from
your own character or if it's well one
of your favorite personal parces go
ahead well yes we were just talking
about this in the Green Room actually
because I say dude a lot and they've now
picked it up and they're saying it which
is awesome and I also say boom because
it just goes with everything you know
good bad generally good just go
boom like that how about you guys and
this is what we deal with every
day yeah my oneliner is get out of my
office right now yeah I don't know
what favorite Yeah in our lives the
whole oneliner idea Cass sort of made
happen it wasn't the intention of the
show and well I'll tell the story
quickly I don't know if you guys were
here yesterday when we did the pilot
episode cia's character had a few things
she said and she was supposed to be cute
but she wasn't like the quick one ler
and we had a scene if you know the first
episode where the Morag who attacked Bo
gets killed and electrocuted and we were
sitting there and cassia comes in with
her um Geraldine ready to go and there
was dead silence on set and I called the
Michelle and I said I need a line for
Kenzie right now and she couldn't think
of anything so how many did she send you
like 10 or 12 Lines by email and no I
think you came you came and they were
like written out yeah I came with a
whole bunch of lines I said pick one and
pick one that we all know is smells like
fried and and and because but
there were a lot of options but that one
stuck out the must me it was because of
that that we decided on the theory that
she would always have one miners so that
was an accident but it worked
well and how MD and how surprised have
you all been by the show's popularity
and particularly for those that have
joined later in the series were you
aware of the popularity when you first
joined the
show no I mean I i' heard of Lost Girl
and um I knew people who watched it and
joining it I think I had an idea that it
was an established popular show but I
remember I was saying to Jay the other
day I remember the night season 3
premiered and seeing on Twitter that it
was trending number one worldwide and
just thinking oh my goodness the show is
so much bigger than I thought and it's
just been a total thrill to to join and
be a part of something that you know
it's so
rad B
well what's your favorite relationship
of the
show I'm sorry I have to say B and
Kenzie I'm going to go with not to be
selfish I'm going to do the same and say
Vex in the Moran that's true okay well
that's that's competition damn it boom
now I have have to say place in t
but
actually I sort of created the Pinky and
the Brain team which is Bruce and Ken
yeah that look if you know the guy Bruce
in the show he just came in my office
one day and I looked up and I said oh my
God I got to make a character for you
and I said I want you to pick Kenzie up
and carrier on her shoulders one day we
tried that but I just thought I called
them pinky in the brain that's true okay
I vote I vote that one good well
KY and for each of you that I'm officer
side here now um if you can have any
guest star on the show who would it be
and
why I would love to have um Adam Driver
he's on a show called Girls on HBO he's
such a cool actor um never know what to
expect from him and every time I watch
that show I go God he make a really good
F do you know him Jay he does know he
doesn't know okay look him up he's cool
I think uh Johnny Depp should come in
and spe his long lost
brother perfect
or or Marilyn Manson no no no no Marilyn
Manson no Marilyn Manson was going to do
the show and he let me down but Johnny
jab me well he let me down because of
Johnny de they went out for tattoos
together and seriously I we were having
behind the scenes of Lost Girl this
behind the scenes Marl Manson was going
to do an episode of the show and we were
supposed to have dinner and then he
calls me up and he says I have to hang
out with d I'll call you L and I said no
no no come on we have dinner no no no I
have to hang out with Deb I'll call you
later and like then he calls me half an
hour later de's in a bad mood I got to
be a good friend I'm not coming and then
I said I'm sitting here in the
restaurant you better show up and he
says okay the tattoos burn we're not
coming they had gotten matching tattoos
all right wow all right that's like
things that girls do together yeah they
got matching
tattoos I see sitcom in that alone yeah
actually I tried to get him to develop
an animated sitcom I got one of the
writers from The Simpsons and he didn't
show up for that breakfast
SE if you could pick any t series you
could do a crossover with which which
would you pick and you can choose like a
reality T Series if you want The Walking
Dead I honestly I I need to be a
zombie she with zombies I am it's true I
Frank I
know Frank are I want to do
uh you guys okay over
there all right well they talk sorry
sorry I'm getting on the set of walking
dead now sorry about that I want to do a
cross over with Homeland so that there
can be all these like CIA phase and and
secretly like the government the United
States of America is full of like fa am
I the only one here am I alone in this
all right I think uh um maybe downt ABY
and uh Morgan can in that
house
no choice no Z wins amazing
all right whatever what about you Jay
what would you like to cross out I just
want Iron Man to show up that's my I
want to be Iron Man I can't exaggerate
that I want to be Iron Man that's why
Halloween's Here Kenzie obviously makes
it through those well really well as a
human on a road but what power would you
choose fa power like to have yourself
which one would you give
the I think um I I got asked this
yesterday and I um um mentioned
something about having a power that
could stop war that could stop you know
the light in the dark from fighting so
whatever form that would take I'm not
sure but I think it would have to be
something Noble um if Kenzie was going
to have it unless it's like a power that
has to do with like
food so stopping war or something with
food I was just wondering what each of
your favorite Kenzie Kong
are Kenzie k
yeah like no like conses down like
dressed up
oh I really loved um playing the shaman
in season two where I got to wear like
the blonde wig and be all like creepy
and Russian and weird and I just
remember just remember being upset with
Anna Anna being like what the hell are
you doing I'm like trust me just let's
just go with this my favorites when she
walks into the jail and lands one on
boat oh God how can I forget that
one yeah all right that's fine Kenzie
would you please do the respectiv for
suers you did yesterday
please B pressure can I can you like box
for me
yeah regret Is for Suckers for suckers
for
suckers for suckers do that
that was that was the
worst we the worst hipop combo ever I
have sense of Rhythm obviously I do
obviously do you have any funny stories
my
set funny stories yeah from set yeah I'm
set while you every day every every
minute of every day um I mean Chris and
I just spill food on ourselves all the
time and on each other we come up I mean
I don't even know sometimes like I'll
open a thing of yogurt and it'll just
like project out Splash onto him or um
so that that's become a bit of a
problem trying to think what we like we
just laugh all day long there's so many
little things that happen all day but
and Anna Anna's the worst too like
she'll start she cannot stop and and
she'll even say like just don't look at
me just just don't look at me so you'll
be doing the scene like this and you can
just feel her like cracking up oh my
gosh it's so much fun they always gets
worse at the very end of the day when
everyone's tired a little bit a little
bit Punchy yeah at 3:00 in the morning
we're all like just laughing
nonstop November is cing up I was
wondering if you could grow a mustache
which you want to
grow I mean speaking of someone who has
tried out all the mustaches on her
mustache app
say my personal favorite and the one
that suits me best is hul co
smach you go b or go
home I want like a like a French one you
know so I can I twisted I know twisted
and twirl it I want like a is it a chaff
um handle bar mustache with a little
little go yeah I really love Kenzie and
ha relationship show we going to get to
see
more God no not at all I mean season 4
just has no love or sexiness or shocking
twists and turns or crazy hookups none
of that so don't even tune in I'm just
kidding that was so expertly avoided
brilliant I've been practicing
so for the all of you then apart from
this probably not apart from J he was
responsible for them what has been the
biggest shock that You' had when you've
been reading this script we can't tell
you not not for season 4 but prev season
yeah season 4 has the most uh you said
not for season I know but I'm just
saying when I think of like most
shocking I I think it's before right
yeah yeah a lot of big reveals
we shock them on a regular basis cuz we
don't let them know what's happening too
far ahead so I like to have them really
like surprise not bring our bces we do
this read through where we all sit
around the table and read the script for
the first time and they crack up half
the time and they go oh my God other The
Times They look surpris I think the most
F was um I had thought in the script or
maybe spoken to Vanessa one of our
producers about uh Dyson and tamson
driving off the cliff and so I told I
told Chris I was like yeah so you hear
like you're dead man like you and I
we're going off the clip Chris is like
what what a Deb I was like yeah like
godone you know and just like playing
into that and Chris freaking out about
it and he was disturbed about it CH
Chris Chris texted me that day and said
I'm buying a new house am I going to be
brought back or
not an answer oh my
God what about three each of you it's
been your it's a favorite part of your
character that you like the
most come on come on evil um I love
being able to say and do the things that
you know you never get to do in in real
life or say the things that you'd want
to say to people um sometimes and you
have to be politically correct or boring
boring and you get I get to do that with
the Morgan I get to be
fun and and mean in a sort of delicious
way and torture people like
Kenzie oh I can't talk about that um
anyways I think I enjoy Kenzie's uh
fashion sense and uh sense of humor the
most I just love what like a little
Tanson
is that's it yeah
that was her character description I
asked for a girl that had a face of the
Ang that could be a real that's
what I was looking for
Ching I watched Lost Girl on my sofa
with four bags of popcorn and I was
wondering how each of you watch this
finished product if you watch it
together the exact same
way yeah um ex like this when I'm on
screen yeah yeah lots of popcorn and
wine friends family you know I bought
them a popcorn machine this year I know
for the pre-show we ate a lot of popcorn
yeah A lot's a popcorn machine I didn't
see the popcorn machine it's now hiding
I just bought it for them is it in your
office now it'll be my office next
week J just wanted a popcor machine it
has nothing to do with us
actually one of the things I do really
love about Samson is sort of the
multi-dimensional character character
that she is um I love playing tamson at
her most
vulnerable I think that that's such an
interesting part of her I love I I love
playing tamson GED because it it allows
you to sort of like deconstruct her down
to that really vulnerable I I love her
humor I love tamson's humor and it's
been such a pleasure to get to explore
that more um and I was saying this
yesterday that I also really want to
explore tamson's heart a little bit more
and what makes her happy and um you know
she has such a purpose for her life but
is really quite devoid of happiness and
so I'm excited to sort of um delve into
that more too so thank you
Jen what's your favorite loving tal
book
te what team we have to pick
teams I always vote team
D yeah I think I have to go with that
too all right wait we have to do a bit
of a vote though yeah okay hands up for
team
Dyson all right hands up for team
Lauren hands up for team
tamson see Dyson wins
Sor all right I'll
just the episode I think it's in season
2 where you're all in the in the D and
you're all spot bodies um I really like
seeing keny and ni body um if you swap
bodes if you can choose which car to
your character SWAT bodies with which
one would it
be so if we could all switch bodies with
someone on like a character on the show
or just like generally or anybody on the
show or generally either well I take
this stud muffin over
here but on the show I can switch Bo to
someone probably Chris it's like ripped
I know Chris yeah
that true
that uh v i okay V good choice too to be
an actor you really have to be
passionate about acting um and I suppose
producing show as um how
did you decide to become actor a
producer you guys go first mine was an
accident mine was sort of a happy
accident too I think always loved
performing
um and I I fell into acting and um it
was something that I sort of did
sporadically as a as a child a child a
teenager and um took a break from it and
then came back and it was a lot harder
when I came back and it it really
focused my desire to to want to be an
actor and it it really made me claim
being an actor as well because I sort of
dabbled in it before so I never really
identified myself as an actor but
um yeah it's it's a bloody brilliant
thing um I grew up in a family of
theater actors and Aras um and I have
grandmothers and aunts and cousins who
all kind of grew up in the theater um my
grandmother is still teaching in the
theater so I grew up in the
wings um watching mostly the women in my
family and I always wanted to be like
that so for me um I never even thought
about it it was kind of something I did
from a very early age and you know all
my friends in high school would be like
I don't know what I want to do and I
don't know what I want to study in
University and I would always kind of
sit back in those conversations and it
it just never I had no other options
like this was
it um for me I grew up I always love
performing I I grew up you know in
school doing plays and things and never
really occurred to me that I could
actually have a career doing that um and
uh and I kept thinking of do I want to
you know do I want to be a lawyer do I
you know be a doctor or whatever no I
can just play those on
TV so then I
did here we are
what but then it becomes R because
you're like well I played a paramedic so
I got this you know people are like
you're not actually
Tred I would like to hear from all of
you if there was a moment when you got a
scraped and went like oh my God no yes
no what the
and if there are too many of those
what's the more most memorable thank you
a a lost girl script Yes
yes again I I am sorry I have to see
season 4 I think all of us every bre
through um felt some sort of oh my God
ah
no1
41 uh I'm just saying that's a see they
all get in very big trouble
yeah 41 413 4 we decided to really shake
it up so season 4 has stunned all the
actors and everybody cuz it's a very
different
season well ladies and Gentlemen please
join me your massive random Applause for
our L go
panelist thank you guys thank you for
[Applause]
having